la capitale ukrainienne kiev se
préparent à l'assaut voyez les images de
ce samedi matin comment les habitants se
prépare-t-il dans quelles conditions
avec quels moyens écoutez cyril payen
envoyé spécial de france 24 en ukraine
il y à quelques heures il était avec
nous à l'entrée sud de kiev
il ya eu ce phénomène de panique que
nous avons bien suivi il ya quelques
jours avec ses plus longues colonnes de
blindés et de tanks russes qui fondait
sur la capitale qui semble prendre du
temps à arriver à ses fins ce qui donne
donc cette fontaine d'opportunité je
dirais pour la population toute entière
à se préparer à cette auto défense a
assiégé à cette ville qui devient une
ville totalement fortifiée et c'est ça
qui est assez saisissant est ce qu'on a
pu voir d'ailleurs à 30 ans en
traversant ce pays d'ouest ici vers la
capitale en en parcourant 700 km c'est
cet énorme effort de mobilisation de la
population tous les habitants de kiev
qu'ils soient étudiants qu'ils soient de
tous les corps de métier quels que
soient leur génération quels que soient
leur engagement politique est bien pour
ceux qui restent ici ce qui reste dans
l'oblast de kiev c'est à dire toute
cette région administrative qui
parcourra périmètre de plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres carrés tous ceux
qui sont ici bien sûr le sont en général
comme ils nous le disent pour rester
jusqu'au bout pour défendre la ville
comme aussi pour défendre les autres
villes périphériques 1 là où il ya déjà
des des combats je pense haïr pin qui se
trouve au nord de là où je me trouve à
20 km où il ya des combats importants
qui ce qu'ils se trouvent et puis bien
sûr le sud qui est sous attaque vous le
disiez comme la ville de mario paul qui
est assiégé donc c'est tout un pays on
le sent bien et c'est ça qui est assez
extraordinaire qui est en train de se
mobiliser avec cette population et s'ils
n'étaient pas prévus évidemment dans le
scénario du kremlin mais cette
population qui compte tenir et parmi les
nombreux barrages militaires qu'on a pu
voir et bien une grande partie était
aussi conjointement tenus par des hommes
de tous âges encore qui avait une arme
des armes de chasse toute arme possible
mais qui s'équipaient qu'ils étaient
déterminés à bunkeriser et bien c'est
défense pour empêcher ce qu'on appelle
l'envahisseur russe d'arriver et de
fonds et de prendre la capitale kiev
les moyens on l'a bien compris ces
villes en tout cas ce sont des moyens de
fusil de chasse comme vous l'avez dit il
sont dérisoires par rapport aux chars
qu'en est il des moyens militaires cyril
connaît-il de la protection militaire de
kiev
alors là évidemment on est tenu par
d'abord les éléments de langage c'est
une guerre informationnelle c'est une
guerre de chiffres chacun des deux camps
avance des chiffres toujours un peu
faramineux un peu fantaisiste par
exemple que mais s'est aussi tenue
évidemment au secret défense du
ministère de la défense ukrainien il y à
des informations parcellaires ce qu'on a
vu sur place non pas évidemment pour
l'instant vu de soldats russes en ce qui
concerne les ressources militaires
ukrainienne eh bien on envoie des défis
les incessants s'est défilé incessant ce
sont des camions qui partent vers kiev
remplis de soldats ou de volontaires et
qu'on voit comme on le prenait le sens
inverse vers l'est en direction du sud
de kiev hier avant leur arrivée et bien
qu'ils repartent à vide pour chercher
des militaires nous avons croisé des
véhicules à des véhicules deux
importants portant sur ed des tanks des
véhicules blindés pas un très très grand
nombre mais ans henry qui a une
mobilisation il n'ya pas d'avion on a pu
voir par ici c'est fameux avion qui
résistent qui ferait qui organiserait
cette résistance aérienne de l'ukraine 2
contre l'invasion russe et qui a
beaucoup surpris les théoriciens
militaire de moscou y qui retiendrait
actuellement évidemment cette avancée
vers capitale par la capitale kiev qui
est aussi capitale pour pour la pour
l'offensive militaire russe sur le plan
des bilans c'est de la même chose il y a
les des rumeurs les plus fantaisistes
officiellement ici on parle de 9000
soldats russes qui seraient tombées
depuis huit jours contre 1500 du côté
ukrainien du côté russe le bilan
officiel et ça c'est un signe que tout
se passe pas aussi bien que prévu on
parle de 500 près de 500 soldats tués
1500 blessés ce il faut trouver ligne
médiane on les plus proches en fait 2500
je dirais selon des sources du
renseignement militaire américain 1500
soldats tués
pour l'instant 1500 du côté ukrainien
des centaines de pertes civiles donc
déjà on voit bien qu'on est entrée dans
un conflit qui n'était pas le conflit
qui était prévu par une offensive éclair
et une prise éclair de l'ukraine par
moscou mais aussi malheureusement et on
le voit ici un conflit qui va durer et
est dans le bilan va s'alourdir
considérablement quel que soit le camp